l'irak a repris son offensive après
quelques jours d'accalmie les tanks
irakiens se dirigent toujours plus
profondément en territoire iranien et
notamment sur la route d'agde oise une
capitale provinciale
il y à trac trois jours les volontaires
de plus de 65 ans étaient engagés et
l'armée irakiennes fait même appel aux
enfants un reportage de notre envoyé
spécial
alain chaillou contre l'iran contre le
régime raciste de khomeiny chaque jour
la propagande irakiennes se déchaîne
ainsi l'a voulu le mettre de l'irak
saddam hussein qui dirige son pays d'une
main de fer pour encadrer la population
pour la surveiller aussi il y à la
milice populaire
deux cent cinquante mille personnes et
parmi eux beaucoup de garçons et deux
filles de 8 à 18 ans qu'on appelle avant
garde ou pionniers enrégimentés
endoctrinés ils suivent leurs cours dans
des écoles spéciales apprennent par
coeur la doctrine officielle celle du
parti baas parti socialiste laïque au
pouvoir depuis 63 et répète que saddam
hussein et le nouveau nasser du monde
arabe
menon la lutte avec saddam hussein avec
lui nous triompherons des infidèles de
ceux qui ne croient pas même nous les
enfants nous savons que la patrie ne
veut pas doux
on a peine à croire en les entendant
qu'il s'agit du même saddam hussein qui
a noyé l'opposition dans le sens fait
pendre en place publique il ya quelques
années
23 officiers parce qu'ils étaient
communistes et en juillet dernier fait
exécuter l'imam gars vers sadr leader de
la communauté chiite
les jeunes pionniers en uniforme bleu
jusqu'à 12 ans et en tenue léopard belge
ensuite on les voit partout dans bagdad
où il participe efficacement à la
défense civile depuis le début du
conflit
ils étaient 13 cents dans le camp où
nous avons pu les films et à l'ouest de
bagdad
chants et marche pour tous et pour les
plus âgés entraînement de commandes aux
entraînements au close combat et séances
de tir leur arme préférée la kalachnikov
soviétique à tous ces exercices garçons
et filles participent avec une ferveur
quasi mystique et tous trouvent juste la
guerre pour le châtel arabe écoutez
plutôt djemila elle a dix ans l'armée
irakienne c'est qu'il ne faut pas
prendre la terre des autres
mais si elle a pris position sur l'autre
rive du châtel arabe c'est parce que ces
terres nous appartiennent est ce que le
gouvernement iranien doit savoir c'est
que nous ne céderons pas et qu'il devra
nous rend ce qui est à nous tous suivent
les événements du front avec la plus
extrême attention la résistance
iranienne les a surpris bien sûr mais
ils n'ont pas perdu la foi et croit dur
comme fer à la victoire finale
il brûle aussi tous des envies d'aller à
la guerre
es-tu prêt à aller te battre oui as tu
envie d'aller à la frontière oui et tu
prêt à tuer tes ennemis
oui et spécialement khomeiny c'est ainsi
alors que dans le monde les enfants du
même âge s'amuse parfois à jouer à la
guerre les gamins de bagdad peu rêve de
la faire vraiment